foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong I am Mark Ellis but she's back in
the States after a whirlwind trip to the
Cannes Film Festival Jacqueline Coley
you're back in the home office how was
Francais
um daunting but fun
uh anytime you're trying to see 30
movies in a small amount of days it's
always going to be a little bit but who
can who who could complain when your job
is to watch movies and more
appropriately who would listen so I'm
happy and glad to be back I saw pics
from the hotel folks and it looked like
a very nice palace that Jacqueline was
staying at with a very I will say a
productive happy hour so that's uh I'm
glad you had a good time but I am always
happy that you are back next to me doing
this show because today we get to talk
about I'm gonna go ahead and say one of
our all-time favorites right I mean you
think about the movies in this guy's
filmography and it's like we grow up
with this stuff and that would of course
be Adam Sandler he's got a new movie
Hustle coming out later on this month
where he plays a Down and Out NBA scout
who's on his last legs hoping to find
the next great Prospect overseas but
today we get to welcome in director and
actor Mark O'Brien he's got a new film
The Righteous streaming June 10th
everywhere it's a really really cool
horror movie getting great views 90
percent on the Tomato Meter thus far and
we're talking about a guy who maybe the
Tomato Meter doesn't love quite as much
because Adam Sandler is his average for
comedies is 28 and his average for his
serious quote roles is just fresh with
61 percent the audience score is
improved for his comedies that goes
almost to Fresh 56 but so we have like
your your Billy Madison's your Big
Daddy's uh Happy Gilmore The Waterboy
we're going to talk about a lot of those
and then some few other ones I I want to
highlight as well when we uh get mark on
the show here and again it's just it's
so exciting to have a guy like that who
is an award-winning actor you've seen
him in Ready or Not Blue Bayou and then
uh season two of Perry Mason on HBO Max
but he also has the righteous coming out
sooner rather than later so Jacqueline
before we welcome Mark we get to two
minutes with Tim just if I ask you hey
Adam Sandler movies go what's the first
kind of not movie but thought that that
pops into your mind regardless of their
reception or what people think of them I
think he's having a good time man you
and me would have been such a good team
like back in the 80s making video
jackets because I could have written
like the quick description and then you
could have put like the critic quotes in
there and like we would have we would
have gotten a lot of rentals back in the
prime of Blockbuster but for now it's
our own Blockbuster Talent Tim Ryan is
our expert review curation manager and
he does his segment two minutes with Tim
which tells us what the critics were
saying at the time of a film's release
or hear how the critics feel about one
Adam Sandler take it away sir
Bergman is one of Cinema's most
important and influential figures with
masterpieces like the seventh seal wild
strawberries Persona and scenes from a
marriage to name just a few Bergman
expanded the medium's emotional and
visual boundaries to previously
unexplored Dimensions after his death in
2007 bergman's house on the Swedish
island of phora became a shrine to the
great director and if you visit you can
see his DVD collection there you'll find
nestled between dozens of Timeless
masterpieces is a copy of Anger
Management in other words everyone's got
a soft spot for the Sandman of course
whether you prefer the serious dramas or
the goofy comedies or if you love them
all there's no doubt Adam Sandler has
had a fascinating career and the
critical response to his films is all
over the map so right now for the sake
of the show we're going to run through
some of those personal favorites bill
Billy Madison from 1995 is rotten at 41
percent with 49 reviews the water boy
from 1998 is rotten at 33 percent with
75 reviews Big Daddy from 1999 is rotten
at 39 with 93 reviews in terms of the
critics the best reviewed Adam Sandler
movie is the marowitz stories new and
selected which is certified fresh at 93
with 188 reviews his worst reviewed film
is the ridiculous six which is rotten at
zero percent with 36 reviews so what did
the critics have to say about those two
in a fresh review of the marowitz
stories Gregory Wakeman of Metro wrote
the marrowette stories are the ultimate
proof of the acting Heights that Sandler
can reach as he embodies the pent-up
aggression frustrations but indomitable
Spirit of Danny marowitz in an
increasingly rich and inherently
hilarious fashion however in a rotten
review for the ridiculous 6 Justin Chang
a variety wrote the scenery ain't bad
but the laughs are Tumbleweed sparse and
they're ridiculous six a western stand
up so lazy and aimless it barely
qualifies as parrot D so that's Adam
Sandler and I would say that's that
mattress man
back to you folks
[Music]
we are now joined by director and one of
the stars of the movie The Righteous
this is Mark O'Brien mark it is such a
pleasure to have you on the show talking
about someone who we all grew up with
right this is Adam Sandler and we love
him dearly as a person the Tomato Meter
not quite so much first of all how are
you doing thank you for being here I'm
doing great I'm so excited to be here uh
like anyone I think in our rough age
group we don't need to reveal numbers
here but uh yeah Adam Sandler is a part
of my DNA I love talking about him and
he's all over the board man on the
Tomato Meter he really is yeah but
before you got here Jack and I were
talking about his overall averages right
and so he's got his his comedic movies
which he's known primarily for those
films average
28.6 percent
on the Tomato Meter now
we we we get a little bit better we
actually get fresher with his serious
quote-unquote roles those films average
61.5 percent which just does get him
into fresh territory on the Tomato Meter
but I'm looking at the sort of list of
movies that we all had emailed back and
forth about what we really want to talk
about why Rotten Tomatoes is wrong about
Adam Sandler feels like we're going to
have a comedy discussion here yeah it's
a lot of Comedy also we can definitely
talk about there is a skew against
comedy on the Tomato Meter it's
something that we talk about at Rotten
Tomatoes This is not to say that like
we're rigging it but by and large
comedic movies don't receive the same
critical Acclaim and you don't even need
Rotten Tomatoes to do that how many
comedies are nominated every year at the
Academy Awards it's kind of like goes in
that same sort of mindset sometimes for
what people view to be great and so when
a comedy rises above like a few of his
yeah it means something Mark I'm curious
for you even before we get to your your
specific Adam Sandler movie that you
want to defend here today when you just
think or somebody asks you hey what do
you think of Adam Sandler movies is
there an easy answer you can give them
or do you have to get specific do you
have an overarching sentiment about his
filmography
I do
um but I think everyone's particular if
I were to ask someone else to not answer
your question and go into my own
question which I'm apparently doing
right now if I were to ask someone else
what do you think of Adam Sandler movies
I would need to know their entire
psychological history where they went to
school how old they are I need a blood
sample because certain people from
different walks of life the first time I
saw punch truck love everyone was
leaving the theater so it's like because
they thought it was an Adam Sandler
movie quote unquote and that was one of
the first the first dramatic ones so
it's such a it's such a confusing
element
um when I think of Adam Sandler movies I
generally feel um excitement because
even if it's one I don't really want to
see Hubie Halloween QB Halloween I just
I'm still like oh he's doing silly stuff
and he's having fun it's like I'm happy
for a man I'm like good for him that 500
million dollar man like it's weird we
all like just want him to do well I'm
excited to see him doing anything and
it's it's it's a really weird sort of
Joy I get from someone I don't know
you know it it's funny that that Mark
brings up our backgrounds Jacqueline
because I think that Adam Sandler when
he first came on the big screen from SNL
sort of appealed to folks like me who
were good at sports but not as good as
we wanted to be and there's a lot of
anger there and how do you express your
anger if you can't beat the other team
all the time you tend to act out like
you would see in a movie like Happy
Gilmore which again I think criminally
low in the Tomato Meter 33 percent but
nobody is here today to highlight Happy
Gilmore as a film although I think we
can all Champion that movie somewhat so
I'll turn it back over to you first Mark
O'Brien what is the film that you see on
the Tomato Meter and you say how could
the critics have gotten that one so
wrong if it's Billy Madison I mean yes
it's really Madison like it is it is it
informed my life to such a large degree
I walked by the other day I'm shooting
uh Perry Mason and I walked by a crew
member the other day and he said uh he
was like it's it was lunch time and he
goes we got some sloppy joes I said lady
is scaring us and and we started
laughing at me and everyone was like
what and it's not even a joke that scene
is not even funny but it just hit a
weird sort of zeitgeisty thing and then
you say and then as I walked away he was
like conditioner is better and
it's but but here's the thing here's my
argument on this I was thinking about
this a lot before coming on I was like I
kind of get the critical reaction I went
back and watched it and I was like
this is weird man like this is a bizarre
movie however here's where I think the
critics are wrong
that it's an incredible setup that is a
great conceit for a movie it's fantastic
in its conceit and all the little weird
stuff was just really like 90s kind of
SNL stuff so like the the jokes that
were like weird and conditioners better
and shampoos better like that was kind
of like weird snla sketchy type kids in
the Halls actually too like that very
sort of meta sketch show yeah 100 and I
just think that it's like I think it's
wrong and I'm like this is a wonderful
setup it's a breezy movie it flies by
and you can't wait for him to go into
the next grade into the next grade into
the next grade and I'll tell you
um also just because I'm excited about
it my favorite part of the movie is when
he's sitting down at dinner and uh and
his and he's like eating his soup and
he's like
like a maniac
and his dad's like a you know
uh Billy these men flew like a long way
they want to miss their flight tonight
he's like well this guy can stay in my
room I'll tell you that much and grabs
his hand and starts biting it that's
enough Billy
because you took your own sweet ass time
coming down here tonight uh these
gentlemen are going to miss their last
flights home well this guy can stay in
my room I'll tell you that much
that's my favorite part of the entire
movie anyway
um I think it's a beautiful conceit and
it's actually kind of heartfelt and I
think when you actually lay it out of
what it is like structurally it's kind
of perfect it's it's sweet and beautiful
and coming of age I have good news for
everyone because uh this is actually the
most well-regarded film The the three of
us are highlighting today because Billy
Madison is all the way up to 41 on the
Tomato Meter so Jack and I have movies
that are even lower than that but
sticking with Billy Madison the conceit
works because he's just this this man
child who's been spoiled his whole life
and now in order to pursue any one of
his dreams that he has however
ridiculous they may be including taking
over his dad's company he has to have a
high school diploma and so he just has
to start back through kindergarten and
just make sure that he passes each grade
and that gives so much opportunity to
have these little ridiculous things that
make no sense in any other movie I think
of Josh most uh principal character who
is just he's just there but then he also
becomes this wrestler the revolting blob
and then I also think of one of Billy's
friends who for no good reason in the
movie during one of his graduation
ceremonies is just spraying a kid with a
hose and that's it and the kid is just
saying I don't even know you what are
you doing and it just gets to this weird
psychologically dark place that we can
all laugh at and Norm Macdonald already
Langer at his graduation Center like why
are they there
I'm like it makes no sense that they've
shown up at all and then when they go on
the the pee your pants thing and then
why is Chris Farley the whole thing he's
like that Veronica Vaughn like his
character does not need to be in the
movie I feel like that that is that is
Testament to your earlier claim that
this was really just a lot of silliness
that you would see in a wacky SNL sketch
in the 90s because as we know it the SNL
in the 90s everyone would do whatever
they could to work Farley into a sketch
somehow because he was just that
brilliant comedically and so it's like
if we need to have him as this creepy
school bus driver that just shows up
randomly and I think that set the
template for the future Sandler movies
and and other films where it's just like
let's just get Farley in this thing
somehow yeah it's meant so much so many
people when we did ready or not we shot
at the mansion that they shot at really
wow yeah and you know when he like he
finishes a conversation with his dad and
then he just dances down the stairs to
like a like some like kind of Moroccan
kind of vibe
when we went to the house and I'd heard
I was like oh my God the house is the
Happy Gilmore or is the Billy Madison
house and I I went and I saw the stairs
like that's the stairs and I went up and
I did the dance down like to like one of
the other cast members and I was like
embarrassing myself and a bunch of crew
members were walking by like what the
hell is this stupid actor doing and then
about a half dozen guys were like yeah I
did that when I came in
[Music]
WoW because I recognized it that's kind
of cool I I guess that's a great
question for you Mark and Jacqueline too
is like how was that movie it's one
thing to say well yeah it's a funny
movie and it showed that Adam Sandler
can carry a film even if it's very
Juvenile and sophomoric but how has it
managed to stay in our our culturals
like as like you said there's this might
be the most quotable Adam Sandler movie
for me I will quote Norm McDonald at the
beginning when he says this is the
greatest night of my life when they're
just uh you know waiting waiting poop on
fire I will the the best quote in that
movie and the one that I think is one of
the most brilliant line lines I've heard
since I became a comic is when Billy has
to defend
his his uh the book that he read at the
at the debate and he's talking about the
pup who lost his way and he goes through
this whole thing and we think it's just
going to be this big sappy he wins off
of this argument and instead the ruling
is we are all now Dumber for having
heard that it's so brilliant how has it
lasted I award you no points and may God
have mercy on yourself that that is
women who make it work whenever you have
absurdist comedy like this you have to
have like a lightning rod of like
straight facedness and and for this one
it was Veronica Vaughn like in later
movies sometimes the girls are crazier
than the dudes you know what I mean but
in this particular one Veronica's the
level-headed one and then just moments
like that where somebody is like did we
just see what we just saw and who's the
corporate guy who's trying to take over
the company away from me
what's his name Bradley Whitford Bradley
Whitford thank you reprising his entire
role from Attack of the Revenge of the
Nerds again basically that guy grew up
right yeah the one thing nerds could
always hang their hat on is like being
being more educated than everyone else
is being able to articulate how they're
feeling more than the bullies but now
now the Nerds have all the power in
Hollywood which is great news for for
all of us but if you right like it is
stuck with us so much like do you know
how often I'm sitting next to someone
and they say something to me and I'm in
a group of people It's relatively quiet
I always say no I won't make out with
you
[Laughter]
it just comes out it's just like it's
like saying you're welcome
the thing I just normally say so I don't
know like what do you think I don't know
the reason why it's stuck this was also
a time when like teenagers had huge I
would say pop culture influence that was
in the mainstream because it wasn't
relegated to the internet now with the
internet what kids are about it's like
you have to be on the right platform
follow the right artists to really even
know and they're allowed to Niche
themselves in a way different way than
they did I mean just think about it
think about it now in sync and
Backstreet Boys that was like today show
material that they were talking about
the war between these two pop bands and
now you have to be a band as big as BTS
for people to even understand who you
are like the relevant versions of that
and so I just think it has to do with
the fact that at that time teenage
culture or young adult culture was pop
culture and so when we look back on that
time with Nostalgia it's not like it was
in the 70s or 80s where it was way more
what the mainstream were about and it's
definitely not the way it is now where
it's so underground I think that's why
it stuck with it is because
at that time this was comedy what Adam
Sandler did was an entire genre of
Comedy SNL was an entire genre of comedy
and so if you just liked comedy at that
time you're gonna kind of be a fan of
these things and that makes it stick
well and you're right and he has
maintained his status and his stardom so
that people go back and watch it so
they're like oh I everyone's talk all
these people who are 10 years older than
me are talking about Billy Madison I
guess I should watch it that that's also
his characters too because you look at
somebody like Billy Madison who you'd
never want to hang out with in real life
or even Happy Gilmore because he can
just fly off the handle at any minute
but we like those characters
intrinsically for some reason and so
even when they have their meltdowns we
root for them and I don't know if Adam
Sandler and Mike Myers ever had these
conversations I don't know if they ever
like even hung out at SNL but I think
that Sandler movies owe a debt of
gratitude to Wayne's World because when
that movie hit it was like this new
every group of teenagers wants to rebel
against what the standard was before
them and so whereas in the 80s you had
these huge comedy movies that were a
little more family skewed like with Bill
Murray and Ghostbusters or with Tom
Hanks films or Eddie Murphy now it's
like no this is Our Generation movies
that our parents might be like there's
no story here this is just a bunch of
nonsense but I think that that is sort
of like the way the Grunge music came in
around the same time it's just something
that was different and that felt like
they had ownership over you know and and
I think it I think it stems from that
there's also something interesting too
of like you know I'm trying to think of
a I'll say Steve Martin it's a bad
example but it's it's not a terrible
example
that guy's been doing comedy for forever
I love Steve Martin well when Steve
Martin if he's not funny in something
you almost feel like that's he's such an
intelligent uh comedian who's been so so
old school too in a lot of ways like him
and Martin Short when they do their live
show which I saw once at Greek Theater
was amazing but it's so old school that
if he Alters you almost feel bad for him
and you're like oh it didn't work
where's Adam saying you're like yeah
he's just screwing around anyway like
you know laugh it off so you don't
you're like who cares about Jack and
Jill he probably thinks it's silly too
and he's cultivated that Persona a
little bit from like just the way that
he navigated everything like I don't
think he's ever navigated things with
that more than just like I just want to
hang out with my friends make the movies
I want to make but if you're careful
you'll see the things that he cares
about
like really cares about because if you
look at it he has a special production
company he uses only for his autor stuff
and that's what he used to produce uncut
gems that's what he used when he was a
producer on I believe rain on me and
funny people and not saying they all
worked but and now this new movie that
he's about to come out with hustle is
also produced by that same banner and so
like it goes to show you where he sees
himself so uncut gems is 92 percent on
the Tomato Meter however what's funny
about that the audience score is only 52
which makes it rotten and so the
audience score currently for Billy
Madison is running laps around uncut
gems it's 79 and so I I think that that
a lot of that shows how much of an
influence that this movie had not just
over us and and a generation multiple
generations for that matter but it also
sort of set the template for what was to
come with Adam Sandler films where it is
going to be him but it's also going to
be a gaggle of his best buds and they're
just going to figure out a premise to
make a movie which is where we get to
with night 1898 and the movie that
Jacqueline wanted to gush about today
which I'm just gonna say is 33 on the
Tomato Meter if our listeners and
viewers want to guest real quick
Jacqueline you may pull the veil yeah
pull the veil on why it's 33 or just on
the movie yeah so Waterboy this is uh
this is a little bit different for Adam
Sandler because he plays this water boy
for a local football team the Gators in
Florida and basically he is Rudy but if
Rudy was obsessed with water and had a
slightly offensive speech impediment uh
like you know he's doing like his Crazy
Cajun thing but yeah he's the local
waterboy and they find out basically if
he gets angry he has the hitting power
of a Mack truck and so he gets pulled
off of the sidelines as the water boy
and onto the field much of this may of
his mother played by the great Academy
Award winner Kathy Bates and to the
Delight of his girlfriend played by the
oh so crazy in this Edition frusable
this is also why I said like sometimes
the women in these stories end up being
way more rails off both the women in
Waterboy are way more rails off and you
have Rob Schneider coming in with his
now iconic but slightly Infamous
catchphrase of you can do it but it's a
great film I love this film um it's
actually has this whole a special place
in my heart I didn't tell anyone about
this but my dad actually worked on all
the Adam Sandler films as a caterer uh
that was his first gig in Hollywood like
as a he was like a caterer he worked for
Gala catering and then he became a
driver later first black man to be a
part of the uh Union uh the dryer region
in here in L.A yeah wait a minute though
so this movie has a special place my
heart I actually went to this set I got
to see them film it and uh it was filmed
at a university I want to say it in I
want to say it was in New Orleans but
don't quote me on that one it may have
been actually in Florida it could have
it it's a gator white team in the color
scheme Echoes a little bit of the
Florida Gators it's technically the name
of the team I think it's the Louisiana
it's in Louisiana but the name of the
team is the mud dogs the mud dogs and
they filmed it they filmed it in a
Louisiana University anyway so yeah I
went on set and it was like a whole
thing and the one thing I will tell you
is The Testament to Adam Sandler who I
know doesn't love Rotten Tomatoes with
all of his heart or whatever but when I
came to interview him for uncut gems in
Toronto not only did he remember my dad
but his manager did because yeah because
again these guys always work with the
same people the same folks over and over
and over again and my dad did I want to
say like eight movies with him click he
did punch he did a sorry uh he did click
he did water boy he did The Longest Yard
um yeah Mr Deeds he did that one too so
yeah I would just say again and it's
it's it's interesting because I think
his reputation not to put any shade
against Mike Myers but as people started
to hear the stories about the fact that
hey Dr Evil was robbed from Dana Carvey
and some of the stuff that came out
after the Cat in the Hat that's when
people started to be like maybe this guy
isn't so nice I don't know if anybody
else has seen but does anybody know that
Mike Myers has a movie right now out a
TV show no you know why because nobody
cares but everyone knows about hustle
they know about Adam Sandler's next
thing because he's just somebody that
his audience has always wanted to give
them the benefit of the doubt and I
think if you are that person no matter
what you do you can make another Haunted
Mansion or whatever it is haunted uh
murder mystery movie what was the name
of that one murder mystery yeah no
murder mystery literally the simplest
and stupidest title in the world but
Jennifer Aniston or Drew Barrymore in it
and he's there and we didn't even talk
about his incredible rom-com run too
like I really like I was gonna do 50
First Dates but I had to do water boy I
I thought about 50 First Dates I think
it's really good Waterboy I like two
um because it's it's kind of almost like
you know like Rudy if we're Adam Sandler
like it's enjoyable because you know
he's gonna get on the team and you know
he's going to get good which is always
fun and you're going to see him exude
his anger onto other people which we
already know is the Persona of Adam
Sandler that's what he does what like
he's gonna do all that yeah and you want
to see it so it's just exciting it's
almost like watching when you see you
know the shark and Jaws like I can't
wait till he starts sacking people yeah
yeah exactly does it and stuff I just
want to say a couple quotes I love from
it so much was Henry Winkler is funny in
that movie yeah and when he says
remember when he cuts he flashes back to
one time he was really upset and he's
wearing heels and his the phone is not
plugged into the wall anyway and then
he's about you just remembered at that
moment and it's so good and he's like
yeah that didn't work out very well for
me and then he's like leaving the house
and Kathy candy base is so good at two
and he's like you know mama won't let me
play and then he goes when I was younger
I wanted nothing more to get a a uh Roy
Orbison tattoo and Mama wouldn't let me
let me tell you something well Mama
doesn't know won't hurt her then pull
her pants down and has a Roy Orbison
tattoo on his ass yeah yeah and that and
apparently that was Henry Winkler's real
behind too are you serious apparently
apparently that was really yeah yeah
apparently like they did like the
stencil for him also too not the only
movie that he did with Winkler I think
Winkler came back for like two other
films I know at least click winklers and
click yeah yeah and and Lawrence gillier
Jr who plays the kicker in in The
Waterboy which is another phenomenal
role and he's sort of like the the best
friend character too the water boy to
Bobby Boucher he he was quoted as saying
that Henry Winkler was just everything
on that set and I've I came across The
Waterboy at the exact perfect time for
me to love it in my life because I was a
freshman in college and it's still
during that bonding session where you're
just getting to know this new group of
friends that you'll probably take with
you for the rest of your life and we're
all you know big sports fans football
seasons in full swing so we all pile
into don't try this at home kids my
friend had a truck and so there's like
eight of us in the flatbed going to the
movie theater and we see water boy and
we're just quoting it and laughing our
asses off on the way home because I
don't necessarily think it's a movie for
everyone but my god did it if you were a
freshman dude in college you loved
seeing that movie and it also sent the
template for something that I think was
maybe a little dangerous and maybe maybe
it it was some of Adam Sandler's future
misfires were the results of the water
boy because he talked very different in
the water boy he was doing this
ridiculous accent and I think that
because he got away with it so well in
the water boy it's like I can I can do
Little Nicky and talk like that the
whole time I I can do these I can do
Jack and Jill and just and play a
character named Jill also
all albums people forget Adam Sandler
had a huge run of comedy albums like
they're all gonna laugh
voices all the way through you can't
like and those were like mega mega hits
so I really think he just wanted to keep
pushing that forward right so what are
the same version of something like
they're all like the same yeah kind of
world and I think like you know Ellis I
think you make a good point where it's
like once that happened because he was
kind of playing a character when you
walk look back at the performance I
still can't decide if I think it's a
great performance or not I don't know
it's so weird and sort of like committed
well it is committed but it's also like
does this work it doesn't need to though
because it doesn't need to because again
you look at so many of his films and
it's like oh it's this it's like okay so
big daddy this is Annie basically you
know what I mean he just takes all of
these other I would say simple premises
from other movies and all he really does
is dress them up with this Adam Sandler
Man Child sort of like wandering through
there's two things I want to say I have
to quote another one that I realize now
I use in everyday life too like when he
reads a note on the at the over at the
the water table or whatever and it says
eat and kill yourself and he goes not
exactly what I call constructive
criticism I always say that if someone's
like jokingly being really mean to me
I'm like what I call construction
criticism
I really do like that one so much
actually mine that I do have because I
am definitely this girl not with like
men in my life but the other women in my
life that fuse a bulk thing where she's
just like you want me to kill them that
is me that is me you cut off my girl in
line at the bathroom or like said
something Shady out in public like I'm
literally like for his walk being like
you want me to kill them because I will
and now I I want to go to the very next
year chronologically is my movie the the
Jack went into that earlier and that's
big daddy which is 39 on the Tomato
Meter and I feel like this movie you can
you can easily be a Critic and poke
holes in something like Billy Madison or
even the water boy I I feel like big
daddy Rotten Tomatoes got that so wrong
on the Tomato Meter because I feel like
that is a genuinely good comedy I think
it's a sweet movie I think it's
sentimental without being sappy and
there's a lot of Adam sandler-isms in it
but it also shows the that that
character in that film could have been
Billy Madison that could have been Happy
Gilmore maybe Happy Gilmore burned out
on tour maybe Billy Madison decided he
didn't want to take over his dad's
company and he wanted to move to the
city that could be that guy and we're
seeing the evolution and the maturation
of Adam Sandler sort of realizing I
can't quite keep doing the same exact
thing if my humor was sophomoric before
I at least need to now be an
upperclassman in high school as I
progress in my career and so this movie
where he just literally finds a kid on
his doorstep and he ends up having to
raise him it's a little Three Men and a
Baby for a new generation that I think
sorely needed some life lessons in
growing up me realizing this this would
be my sophomore year in college that I
love Billy Madison but you can't act
like that doofus forever but you can
sort of try to base your 20s on a
character like we see in Big Daddy yeah
no hey look yeah the maturation is there
called it you just sold it to me I don't
I'm not a fan of Big Daddy really I
wanted it to be funny I wasn't ready yet
for his
if Big Daddy was direct I mean that's
probably one of his regular directors
like uh Doug or Dennis Dugan
yeah that's always even Braille it's
always like one of those those guys
right I think if I knew if that was like
a PT Anderson at the time I would have
been like all in I think I wasn't I was
the people who walked out of punched on
glove but it was three I wasn't ready
yet so I was like is that funny me too
you just stole it as in like I I you
know I know that movie pretty well and
I'm like it is a really sweet movie it's
really really sweet and you're right it
was a nice move for him to it was
probably what helped him move into
contract love like three years later
like it's like
it was going in that direction for him
of like oh I could like capitalizing on
what he's done before that Persona and
the courtroom scene Jaclyn when when he
when we had this custody battle that
we've been leading towards it's the
perfect combination of some real actual
drama and emotion there but there's also
ridiculous comedy with Steve Buscemi who
was always great whether he's putting on
lipstick and Billy Madison uh whatever
he's doing in an Adam Sandler movie and
here he plays this homeless guy who
hangs outside of McDonald's who they
recruit to be one of the key Witnesses
in this trial for whether Sunny should
be able to get custody and the old guy
is is there who's you know that just
hangs out with him at the bar to watch
the Jets game like it's so Preposterous
but it works yeah it definitely does
work also
um at that time I also like I have to
thank this movie for so many things
first of all it gave us the Sprouse
twins which I was a Riverdale fan and
just a fan of dumois and celebrity
gossip those two are like a lifeblood
they just they always bring a little bit
of the drama so I like that a lot I mean
honestly though too just just the idea
that Adam Sandler could have a movie
like that I was trying to look it up but
I believe
at the time Cisco and Ebert still
arranged Supreme as far as critical
reception and if I recall correctly one
of them liked Big Daddy and I'm pretty
sure it was Ebert but like don't quote
me on that but one of them hated it and
one of them liked it and I wish I could
have figured it out but there were
people who I think got what Big Daddy
was going through the thing I think that
sort of had its Achilles heel is so much
of it was just like ridiculous stuff
like the kid won't shower like it's just
like it's like this man should not and
the plot hole the setup of the plot is
strange
like that guy drops that kid off the
next day like no way that that guy all
of a sudden decides to be this thing and
there's not any way that the teachers
didn't report him 10 seconds after he
came to school saying that he wanted to
call himself Frankenstein like but like
Child Protective Services would have
been notified there's a plate of ketchup
like nobody is letting this child be
alone with this man for so many more
reasons than just how bad he is as a
parent like let's just put that out
there but I get it man I would not in
any way say that it wasn't great my
favorite is like Leslie Mann again
playing like the straight being like
quit being a jerk like just her hatred
of Adam Sandler in that movie is like
one of my favorite things to her
like it's gonna get infected that's why
you don't scratch dumbass
I love it here's my question with big
daddy and Waterboy especially
how do you think they would play today
like if they came out today and Adam
Sandler's in them he could even if he's
the same age even if it was like you
know 30s late 30s Adam Sandler or
whatever
I don't know big daddy works I feel like
big Daddy works yeah he does yeah I
think Waterboy doesn't because of like
obvious reasons but I think big daddy
does with some careful adjustments yeah
like you just have to remove the thing
that was never really talked about which
is this idea of like this is a grown ass
man with a child he doesn't know and you
have to just set that up in a premise
where there's a little bit more
protection like an aunt or an uncle you
just have to change the dynamic it not
just be some random child that was put
on his doorstep it needed a little
massaging let's be honest yeah a little
massaging but oh it's awesome Jon
Stewart in there let's also keep Jon
Stewart as the actual dad who kind of
bookends the movie and yeah it really
was a movie that I I think a lot of guys
who were in my position in life at the
time who loved the the juvenile sense of
of humor of Adam Sandler films but then
that movie put us all in a position
where what if some responsibility in our
future whether it's as as you know big
as having a child or a pet or even just
getting a girlfriend which would have
been news to me it's like maybe this
maybe we do have to show a more mature
side of ourselves than just being
stiffer from American Pie all the time
you know and so I think it was a
formative movie for me anyway it's
say that because as we go through these
movies because I you know you sit down
sometimes think about certain people's
work in in chronological order
and like as movie people like I do that
all the time like oh yeah then they did
that movie then they did that movie he
kind of was like just we were watching
him progress as a human like through all
these movies if you really like look at
it chronologically almost completely
from day one from AirHeads to you know
like it's been sort of a version of his
life
in a strange way or or the personas that
he's played have we've watched them grow
up and maybe like I'm just thinking
about this now maybe that's why he's so
important to us because we've watched
him evolve before our very eyes almost
AirHeads criminal criminally underrated
too I caught it on TV a couple weeks ago
and it still holds up for me another
great Farley Cameo 25
on the Tomato Vader baby a little more
well-deserved where they take over radio
stations so they can get their band
played but that's Brendan Fraser coming
off of Encino Man Steve Buscemi's in it
like there's something
has one of the greatest I'm doing the
wrong thing at the wrong moments in that
movie which is at the end uh spoiler
alert they go to jail for their efforts
as they should that's the other thing
about that movie very fair and he's
playing in jail and he's like doing the
like
and he's like making love to the guitar
but it's an all-male prison and everyone
just looks at him like you don't really
know what you're doing right now do you
and it's like one of the greatest
moments ever of like he's just like I
have committed to something that I did
not realize like like just you don't
know what you're saying when you're
saying this sir and it was like I just
love that non-verbal thing because it's
literally like over the credits best one
of the best jokes in the movie can I can
I throw in an honorable mention is that
okay yeah I'll just I'll really quickly
I loved marwood stories I thought he
should have been nominated for that as
well as well as Uncle James I I I
absolutely I thought he was he broke my
heart into a million pieces in that
movie and I mean there's so many other
movies in his that I I like he's made so
many most of the comedies I don't end up
going for but one of my honorable
mentions a Wedding Singer is fun like of
course I love John Lovitz in that in
that movie and Steve Buscemi in that
movie as well but
uh
uh that's my boy oh yeah was that
Samberg too right yeah exactly and
that's when it was like almost like a
passing of the Baton but that didn't
really end up happening the reason why I
like it is because for a long time I
think you know I don't sound like a very
young kid so he was doing kind of like
you know Mr Deeds Goes to wash or
whatever he's doing all these kind of
like safe and sweet movies Hotel trans
whatever the hell all those movies were
and then all of a sudden he did an
R-rated comedy again that's my boy I
feel like was his first R-rated comedy
in a number of years at that point and
he is cursing up a storm he is he is
playing the Adam Sandler the grown-up
Billy Madison Happy Gilmore character
but we hadn't seen it in 15 16 years or
whatever so I remember going to the
theater I was like I think that was
really funny I'm actually gonna go see
it in theaters and I died I thought it
was hilarious it was everything I wanted
and I actually thought it was gonna be a
big hit and it wasn't really I think it
did okay in the end but critics it was
it was brutalized and I was like I don't
get it isn't this what we've all been
waiting for and I felt like it just kind
of went under the rug I I mean yeah I
agree with that if I can have an
honorable mention I just want to say
Spanglish
yeah this is James Brooks which is 54 on
the Tomato Meter which is very curious I
I was shocked that movie wasn't fresh I
really love that movie it's a very
simple movie it's very much within James
L Brooks the guy that makes
um uh As Good As It Gets is kind of hard
for him to come back with something like
Spanglish which is still good but in no
way as satisfying a film but man I love
that movie so so so much I'll give a
shout out to a a fresh movie that is
also uh what what Mark had hinted at
earlier is uh The Wedding Singer which
is 69 fresh and it's also because as
somebody who watches Adam Sandler movies
and can clearly tell he is a master
appreciator like I am of Van Halen
that's got such a great Van Halen
reference because the movie takes place
in 85 and his ex-girlfriend is wearing a
Van Halen t-shirt and he's like take it
off before you jinx the band and they
break up it's a pretty pretty good one
oh wow pretty good lining I've used that
myself sweetest moment because he when
he's so sweet he breaks your heart right
and
the the song at the end come on I want
to grow old with you is this yeah
yeah yeah
I've listened to that song I sang that
to an ex-girlfriend you did learned how
to play it on guitar and sang it to her
when I was like 19 or 20 years old and
um she was very impressed um
I I wish there was video of this
somewhere
I it is it was throttlingly terrible I
think she just you know felt bad for
whatever it's weird she broke up with me
about a week after
if we broke my guitar over her knee when
she did it which was really unnecessary
that's rock and roll he did not that's
rock and roll baby what do you expect
did not do that
as long as you didn't let her wear your
Van Halen t-shirt we're all good we
could all talk about Adam Sandler movies
all day as we've displayed here but I I
do want to put some shine to uh just the
the filmmaker now in addition to acting
that we have here is our special guest
here Mark O'Brien uh you have a film
that is really took me by surprise
called the righteous because I'll be
honest I didn't know what I was getting
into with this and what I got into was
just a delightful horror trip I'm a big
horror movie fan and the righteous
really really grabbed me and did not let
me go where does like when you're making
a film like that and you're also in the
movie by the way what are some of the
challenges that you faced making that
that you hadn't previously encountered
in your career well I had to
um watch the water boy a lot
happens I like I I had to stay up late
that was a challenge there's only so
many hours in the day
um honestly the biggest challenge is is
just putting it together I I find that
very I don't understand that as well and
maybe it's because I'm I'm more of like
a creative I don't know like the
paperwork so when you're just trying to
convince people to let you do it really
is the thing that I I honestly I hate I
despise it you're basically begging and
I don't have any problems with begging
I'm an actor but it's I just don't like
to do it if I know I'm gonna get it then
it's fine but you're always in a
questioning thing but when it comes to
shooting I actually found it pretty
smooth because
you I knew my movie really well of what
I want to do for better or worse it
doesn't mean it's like when we finished
I was like that's the movie I want to
make I don't know if it's good or not
that's objective to someone else but I
knew the story I wanted to tell so when
you're acting it kind of just it makes
the process a bit more fluid and a bit
more streamlined because I know what I
want from that and I'm an actor that's
what I do for a living and I think some
actors sometimes can be a little cool
and be like I don't know if I can do it
I was like well I wrote it I I know I
can do it like just like you know
someone goes in and plays guitar on a
track they know how to do that that's
what they do so I was like I felt
comfortable with that because I wrote it
if I didn't write it
I don't know if I could ever direct
something I didn't write but especially
acting as well I would find that weird
because it's not my voice so the whole
thing was my voice as one so that helped
Jacqueline that's the best answer I've
ever gotten asking a question like that
and I'll tell you why it's because
that's that's what frightens me about
any Endeavor I'd have to direct anything
it's not getting on set and telling
people what to do and how to tell the
story it's the paperwork it's illegal
it's the red tape that's the it once you
get there it's like okay now let's do
our fun little Barnyard production now
that all of the the lawyers are out of
it that's what that's honesty right
there no it is honesty it's actually the
opposite of mine because the blank page
is the most terrifying thing on the face
of the Earth in my opinion but I was I I
could I could deal with paperwork I grew
up in bureaucracy uh Mark I've talked to
you about this film before which I think
is is so great but I want to set it up
for folks because this was a choice not
just in what you chose to do but how you
chose to do it from like the black and
white setting so just set up the story
for us a little bit and and how you
wanted to do it in the sense of like I
know you used friends and family members
like you did this in like your little
Hometown so yeah give us a quick log
line of the righteous and then why you
brought it all the way back to I'm gonna
say the place where you're from badly so
you do it for me but it's very small
community I know that you wouldn't
expect it to be pronounced it's not the
Fallon it's not new Newfoundland it's
Newfoundland there you go see whatever I
didn't say it could possibly be
pronounced yeah Newfoundland there we go
I don't know what we were thinking what
we named it like I was there in the room
when that happened so it's really the
log line is a a burdened ex-priest feels
the wrath of eventual God after his
visit by mysterious stranger so really
it's a lot of I wanted to take the
preconceived notion of like you know a
stranger in the house kind of thing and
then turn that and twist that and also
twist genre a lot because that's why I
love a as a filmmaker and and Jack we've
talked about it before about like
you know I love Michael haneki and stuff
and I like people who who you don't know
what's coming next and I loved
aronofsky's mother for example like I
love that now the foundations of where I
was really inspired is more back to like
Fritz Lang's early movies and um oh yeah
drier like that's really where it came
from but I wanted to twist that in a way
and I grew up in Newfoundland and I'm a
proud newfoundlander and I go back when
I can but you know I live in L.A it's
across the continent and but I wanted to
go back there for a number of reasons I
wanted to work with the people I know
and love who I grew up with
because I think you get a bread a
product when you're working with people
you like and enjoy being around
even if they weren't talented and they
are but even if they weren't it's still
gonna be a better product than working
with jerks who are talented so I had the
best of all worlds in that way and I
also felt like I'm so proud of where I'm
from and and I was so supported there
like it's you know to come from
Newfoundland and to be working in La is
not an easy thing to do you need a lot
of support and that the community that
really supported me and and supports
everyone and and I it meant the world to
me so I just wanted to not like go back
and pay it back this was a tiny movie
with no budget but I just wanted to be
there
um and be a part of that community in
making it and then outside of that
aesthetically like
I I I the one problem I have with movies
that are set in Newfoundland because
there are some like you know I mean
there there's a couple dozen it always
has to make a point about being in
Newfoundland and and I'm like you don't
need to I'm not one of those people who
it's like the city is the setting I
actually like no place no time because
when you say this is set in New York
1988 you immediately have associations I
don't want associations I want to create
a world that is human and real but we
don't know where and when it is and I
think so growing up in Newfoundland I'd
see these movies set in Newfoundland
they always had to have an accent
they're always fishing and stuff and I
was like why can't I just use the way
Newfoundland feels for me which is cold
and and it's and it's kind of like
nature is very alive there in in a in a
figurative sense it has like it's it's
kind of like mysterious and and and a
life of its own and I was like that
works the setting for this works for
this film so rather than just set a
movie where I'm from I was like why
don't I use the feeling of where I'm
from and that meant a lot to me so there
were a million reasons why I want to go
back and do it there and we had the best
time we shot 15 days that's all we had
we had 16 and we had to cut a day five
days wow I had seven days of prep spread
out over uh four weeks I I was shooting
Blue Bayou and I went from New Orleans
to St John's for four days went back to
New Orleans for two weeks then came back
for three days and then started shooting
the fourth day so we had no time and and
no 650 000 Canadian but we all were
having a good time and that's why it was
good like I think like that's why it was
a good experience I should say I mean
and it is like I want to give you give
your praise here it's it's being
released uh on Arrow it's already 90 on
the Tomato Meter well on your way to
certified fresh sir and we'll get that
to you as soon as you can uh wrapping
everything up here it was sort of a fun
fact I weren't really quick before we
say goodbye uh because we were talking
about the artistic choice that you make
when you're making a film like the
righteous did you know that one of the
original concepts for Jaclyn's movie the
water boy was to have it set in 1950s
New England and make the movie in black
and white
that was one of the original concepts
for the water boy and still still make
it a comedy but still take it in a
different direction where it's like sort
of those ivy league college football
rivalries and uh it would have been a
different movie that's when Michael
Hannity was attached to director Mark
O'Brien you're always welcome at our
reindeer games it was such a pleasure
having you the the movie is the
righteous and it's available streaming
everywhere as of June 10th and I'm
seeing the critic reviews on Rotten
Tomatoes here they're calling it one of
the best horror movies of the year and I
would certainly co-sign that endorsement
so congratulations as we say goodbye
here do you have any any movie or TV
show in addition to obviously the
righteous and some of our favorite Adam
Sandler movies that you want to
highlight really quick we usually get a
streaming recommendation from our from
our uh lovely crew membership or
something in general in general or
whether you're working on also I want to
make sure we shout out 61st Street which
you guys just did the finale last week
yes those haven't caught that they can
definitely kept that out yeah anything
you're watching anything you want to
shout out oh god
um oh you know what I'm really into the
Columbia Noir Blu-ray that Powerhouse
indicator yeah there's a great one
that's totally under the radar with
Edmund O'Brien that I had never seen
called 7-Eleven Ocean Drive I'm obsessed
with those old Noir movies and some of
them are kind of like all the same
they're like you know just turning them
out that one is phenomenal 7-Eleven you
can drive with Edmond O'Brien it's like
I'm gonna check that out Mark O'Brien it
was a pleasure having you please come
back soon anytime you feel like chatting
movies we're always here for you I would
love it thanks so much guys this is so
much fun thank you see you next time see
you guys thanks again it's always fun
having guests on here because inevitably
Jacqueline has known them and
interviewed them and interacted for
years prior and so we we kind of have a
soft Landing but I mean Mark O'Brien was
so much fun to talk to and he's just one
of those guys you just feel like you've
known him your whole life and I will say
that was one of the reasons why I
there's a lot of folks that that reach
out to us to be on the podcast I'm being
really honest amongst folks we know but
when you have a filmmaker or an actor
like Mark 10 minutes after talking to
him you're like yeah I just want to talk
to you more if you have any suggestions
as far as movies that you want us to
talk about guests you'd like us to have
hit us up email us at RT is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com and sometimes we'll
even read your emails on the air if
you're listening to us make sure you
subscribe if you do all that good stuff
if you're watching us on a streaming
program like peacock thank you for your
support So for Jacqueline Coley our
special guest Mark O'Brien and his new
film The Righteous producing Lucy Brian
Perez Tim Ryan our entire team here at
RT is wrong I am merely Mark Ellis
saying thanks for listening and watching
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you